>>Neil Rhodes: Thanks for coming to this session.
Before I begin, a couple questions.
First off, how many of you currently use Google
Analytics?
So it looks like 50, 75%, somewhere in there.
And of those of you, how many of you use Google
Analytics for mobile apps?
Almost the same percentage, maybe 30%, something
like that.
So for those of you who don't use Google Analytics
at all, it's a way of providing anonymized,
aggregated data about the usage of your software,
and we're going to see that in much more detail.
For those of you who use Analytics but don't
use it for mobile yet, I hope this really
shows you how mobile can be quite useful with
analytics.
And for those of you who are already using
Google Analytics with mobile, I think you're
going to be really excited about what we have
to show you with the new features, new announcements.
So my name is Neil Rhodes.
I'm tech lead for the mobile analytics SDK.
I'm really happy to show you what we've been
working on for the last nine months.
About two years ago, we released an SDK for
mobile analytics.
But it wasn't really a great solution.
So Google Analytics has been really designed
best for Web sites.
And, really, what we said to you when we provided
this SDK was, you can go ahead and use analytics
for mobile applications.
However, you have to pretend you're a Web
site.
Right?
You pretend you're a Web site.
We will pretend you're a Web site.
And we're not going to really give you anything
application-specific.
So how does that pretense work or how did
it work?
Well, for one thing, when you signed up an
account, you had to provide the URL of your
Web site, until recently.
Now, I don't know about you, but I don't have
a URL for my mobile application.
So you had to fake one.
Another example.
All the terminology was Web-centric.
We use terminology like "visit" and "visitors."
I don't have visitors to my application; I
have users.
And I don't have visits; we have maybe sessions.
I don't have page views; I have screens.
And also, I have information that's specific
to applications, things like versions, application
name, things like, well, crashes; right?
That happens.
And it's information you want to find out
about.
So what we're announcing today, what we have
announced today, really, is mobile applications
as first-class citizens at Google Analytics.
Announcing Google Mobile App Analytics.
[ Applause ]
>>Neil Rhodes: Thank you.
So this is available in beta.
We're taking people in via white list.
And we're going to be allowing those people
to enter the beta in waves.
And we expect to have everyone who's using
Analytics available to use mobile apps by
the end of summer.
I'll talk a little bit later about how you
sign up for this white list.
So mobile applications.
When you're developing a mobile application
-- we saw a number of sessions this week about
development.
Actually, let me add one more thing.
When I say "mobile applications," I did say
Android applications?
>>> No.
>>Neil Rhodes: I said the word "mobile," because
this includes both Android and iOS.
So when you're developing applications, you
go ahead and develop them.
And then you market those applications through
a variety of ways.
So you might have paid advertising, email
marketing campaigns, Google Search, and so
on, SEO type things.
And then, my favorite part next to the analysis
is monetizing.
Right?
How do you make money on this application.
We had sessions on this as well this week.
What we're focusing on is the third part,
the measuring and the iterating, that is,
measuring how well your development has worked,
how well your marketing and monetizing are
working, and then improving those and iterating
on them.
For development, some of what you can measure
are -- the sad thing I mentioned earlier -- crashes.
Also measure how people are using your application,
whether there are particular screens that
are not used very much or options that are
not used very much or screens that are confusing
to users and they leave your application.
So by measuring that, you can then go and
iterate and make a better product.
You can measure your marketing.
What happens when users come into your application
via different channels?
How do they act within the application?
How well do they monetize, and so on?
We'll look at some of this in more detail.
We break apart, really, three different areas
of measurement.
So one is acquisitions.
Where are your users coming from?
Are they coming because an email marketing
campaign drove them to Google Play, for example?
Are they coming because they're doing a search
on Google for various key words?
Are they coming because of various advertising
campaigns?
And it's important to get that information.
You want to spend your money wisely if you're
doing advertising campaigns.
A second is engagement.
Once the users actually get there and are
using your application, how are they using
it?
What screens are they using in your application?
For how long?
How do users move within your application
from screen to screen?
That nasty word, app crashes, again.
So we may want to know information about app
crashes, like, what is the crash, of course.
But also where is it occurring within your
application.
What kinds of devices is it occurring on?
What operating system versions?
What versions of your application is it happening
in?
Events.
Think of screens as sort of the where in your
application.
And events is the what that's happening.
So you can add code to your application to
track specific events that are occurring,
things like, for instance, the user choosing
a particular preference item.
Let me pick a specific example.
Let's say you have a menu item to carry out
some task.
What percentage of your users use that menu
item?
Do you have any idea?
Is it 1%?
Is it 50%?
How many users don't even know there are menus?
Probably a fair number.
Right?
And so by causing an event to be tracked when
a menu is chosen, you can have some idea of
how often that's used.
Maybe it would be simpler to not have that
event at all.
Or maybe it happens so often you want to actually
make that happen on screen.
So that's acquisition.
Where do users come from.
Engagement, what do they do when they get
there?
And then outcome.
So we have several outcomes.
One outcome is certainly monetization.
What sales do you have of your application?
What ad revenue do you have?
What in-app purchases do you have?
And I want to look at that information and
slice it and dice it in various different
ways, like per country, for example, or in
a number of different ways that we're going
to see.
We also have the idea of goal conversions.
So you can set up a goal within your application
of, like, reaching a particular screen or
having some particular event happen and see
how users get to that conversion, how many
of those happen and so on.
So now let's look at a demo.
So here I am, and I'm going to create a new
account.
So I've got an application I want to do tracking
for.
And what do I want to track?
Well, what we see is a first-class object
or application.
So we have a Web site, yes.
And if we had a Web site, we would need to
know its URL, of course.
But we're not a Web site.
We're an application we're going to be tracking.
So no need for a URL.
Our application actually has a name.
This is Neil's App, let's say.
And my account.
And then I can go ahead and get a tracking
ID.
First I've got to agree to the terms of service.
My Evelyn woods speed reading class comes
in handy.
And, yes, this all looks reasonable.
And now I get a tracking ID.
So this is the ID -- UA number number number
dash number -- that I'm going to use within
my application to specify that it's for this
account that I am tracking information.
From here, I can easily download the SDK.
So the Android SDK or the iOS SDK, in a single
link.
I have references to the documentation from
here.
A lot of folks monetize their application
using AdMob.
And so if you use AdMob, we have a single
download that actually combines both the AdMob
and Analytics SKDs.
One fewer thing to download.
So I've created this account, but I'm not
going to actually use it right now, because
since I just created it, there's no data there.
Instead, I'm going to look at a different
account.
So this is for an application I call Acme
Travel.
It's an application that's used for searching
and booking hotel and flights.
And in the overview, we provide what we hope
are the most useful graphs and dashboards
that you'd want for looking at this.
And we've organized it in these three ways,
again: Acquisitions.
So here we see how many new users and active
users per day, where they're coming from,
what device model.
Engagement.
How long are they using your application?
How many screens per usage or per session?
What screens are the most common?
And then outcomes.
Goal completions.
And as I mentioned, my favorite, in-app revenue.
So I can see revenues were going up slightly,
and then I had a sudden drop, but that was
made up for by a nice peak.
So graphs and numbers are nice.
But that is not the reason for analytics.
Instead, the reason is to have -- find information
so that you can take action.
Look at an example.
So Google Play sources.
I can see, again, the acquisition.
How did my users get to my application?
So this source and medium tells me -- Google
and CPC tells me, basically, this is an AdWords
campaign.
I also have an email campaign.
Mobile Display is an AdMob campaign.
So this was not me monetizing my app, but
instead, me as an advertiser trying to drive
users to my application.
Organic search.
Google doing a search that led to going to
Google Play.
And other advertising campaigns as well.
And from each of those, I can find out how
many users, how many new users, I got, how
many sessions those users had, the duration
of those sessions, and the in-app revenue.
This is the information that we provide you
directly.
You can certainly make customer reports and
slice and dice information how you want.
What do I get from this actionable?
Well, I see, for example, that my AdWords
campaign had ten new users with an average
session duration of 35 seconds, and they spent
a total of $2,493.
This is probably an exceptionally good AdWords
campaign, actually, with an average of $250
per user.
My email campaign did fairly well.
I had six new users.
So, actually, if I just looked at users, ten
new users in my AdWords campaign, six new
users in my email campaign.
Well, that says that the AdWords campaign
is about 50% better than the other one; right?
But the cohort of people coming in are actually
different.
That is, their behavior is different, depending
on how they got there.
Why might that be?
Maybe the people who came in via my AdWords
campaign, I had a particularly compelling
ad that only people who are quite qualified
would click on.
And maybe on my email campaign it was somewhat
less directed and I had more sort of random
people coming in.
But in any case, I can see how well my ad
worked with respect to the money I got.
And here, clearly, the AdWords campaign went
well.
We'll take questions at the end.
But do save that question.
Look at another question I have.
So this application is in English.
I have enough money, I have enough budget,
to translate it into a single language, to
localize it.
And, unfortunately, one.
As I look at this chart, I see that English
is certainly my predominant use.
So this is people whose devices are set to
use English.
But I also have people who are using it in
German, in Spanish, and French.
Now, again, the application is in English,
but they're on a device that's set up for
German, Spanish, or French.
And as I look at the numbers here, my natural
inclination would be to say, German is obviously
the language to which I should translate next,
because that's the most number of users.
But if I look more carefully, dive into the
numbers a little deeper, I see that the behavior
of the users using German is quite different
from the ones using Spanish.
In particular, the screens per session is
2 for German, which is very close to the English
of 2.09, whereas in Spanish, it's only 1.38.
If I look at the session duration, it's actually
longer in German than it is for English users.
But in Spanish, it's five seconds.
Here's what that tells me.
Here's the story that I get from that.
I could be wrong, but this is my interpretation.
German users, at least of this application,
are willing to use it in English.
They're willing to use it for just as long
as English users.
Spanish users are not.
Okay?
They open the application and they leave pretty
quickly.
So this says to me that although I might affect
more users if I translate it to German, I'm
actually going to improve the life more if
I translate to Spanish, because the German
users are okay with it and the Spanish users
are not.
Does that make sense?
Okay.
Let's look at an overview of devices and networks,
again, to try and get some actionable information.
Top network operators, not that useful to
me, although it does tell me, since we're
using Sprint as the top network operator,
that people are mostly using this via cell
connection and not via Wi-Fi.
So that's useful information.
Key information here for me is the OS versions.
So I see that Android 4.0 is the largest set
of people using my app.
Android 2.1 behind that, iOS just behind that,
iOS 5.
And then some other versions of Android and
iOS.
So what this says to me is that the majority
of people using iOS are using iOS 5.
And, in fact, I wouldn't lose too much of
my iOS users if I required iOS 5 as a minimum
version.
Doing that might allow me to take advantage
of iOS 5 features.
Okay?
And make my life a little easier because I
didn't have to support iOS 4.
On the other hand, it wouldn't make sense,
according to these numbers, for my particular
users for Android.
If I required Android 4 as a minimum, I would
lose a lot of my existing users.
So that says to me if I want to support Android
4 features, I need to make sure to do so in
way such that my application will still run
on earlier devices.
I can see the device models, and that's useful.
Screen resolution is another thing that can
be important; right?
If I know what percentage of people are using
what screen sizes.
This tells me a fair number of people are
using large-resolution devices, high-resolution
devices, and so therefore it might make sense
for me to invest in higher-resolution artwork,
because my artwork right now is fairly low
res.
Let's move now from acquisition to engagement.
I can see information like what screens people
are using, what events are occurring.
One thing that's really interesting is engagement
flow.
So this tells me how people move within my
application from screen to screen.
This particular application doesn't have very
many screens.
It's a fairly simplistic application.
But what I see is -- so this is telling me
on the left that people coming in using the
Android version of the app, and the people
coming in using the iOS version of the app,
and I get to see how many of them go -- start
at the search screen.
So the vast majority of them start at the
search screen.
And in the red here on the right is the dropoff,
how many of them leave the application by
going to the search screen and then leaving.
So we have some number, about 8%, drop off.
The rest of them are moving over to the results
page.
Say I want to narrow down just what are the
Android users doing.
In this case, I see most of them go on to
the search page, but a small portion of them
just go into the login page and then, kind
of weird, go directly into the results page.
I'm not quite sure what's going on there and
that might make me want to look into my application
a little bit.
So this tells me the where of how people move
within my application.
What we've also got is ability to look at
not only the where but also what's occurring
as well.
So I can look at a combination of screens
and events.
Let me start at the results page.
So I can see that the results page, from there
I go to the preferences or the book page somewhat,
but then I also go to these blue events.
So I can see the interaction that's occurring
in my application by users between screens
and between also screens and actions.
Crashes.
So we differentiate between crashes and exceptions,
or rather exceptions are a superset of crashes
because we also have exceptions that occur
that are not fatal.
So crashes are fatal exceptions.
And unfortunately in this application we had
some crashes.
Our 1.1 version had four cashes, our 1.2 version
had 13.
So that might say to us that's not good, it's
not good to have crashes, right, I'd like
to have the number zero there.
Might say just our 1.2 version got worse than
our 1.2 version or maybe it says we have a
lot more usage of our 1.2 application.
We can investigate that a little further.
We have versions of our application for both
iOS and Android in 1.1 and we introduced 1.2.
It's interesting, if I add some information
to this and look at the operating system,
and what I see is it's actually segregated.
The 1.1 version of the application only has
crashes on Android.
And there are none in the 1.2 version of Android.
So that says I had a problem there and I fixed
it.
Unfortunately, what happened on iOS?
Apparently, I was doing great there and I
added a bug.
It wasn't me, it was my partner.
I don't have bugs.
I'm going to fix the 1.2 version of Android,
in fact.
Some of the other reports we can see and how
this is useful.
So this is loyalty.
How many times does a particular user use
your application?
So there are some users that use it once.
And this is during the time period of interest
that we're looking at.
Some people use it between 50-100 times.
It's useful to know how many people use it,
but it's also useful to know how that affects
other parts, how does that affect your monetization.
In this case how does it affect your goal
conversion.
If we look at the goal conversion here, I
see that about session 6, I get a big bump
in my goal conversion from 77% to 92%.
So this may be because users become more comfortable
with my application and then are willing to
go ahead and go to this conversion, which
in my case involves buying something.
So maybe it's important to try and help drive
people who use it more so they become comfortable
so then they can monetize your app.
All right.
And actually the final one I want to show
you is the e-commerce.
And this I don't have anything actionable
right this instant but I love to see how much
money I make, and I can see how much money
I make for each of my products, in this case
I'm selling round-trip air tickets and so
I can see that I'm selling a lot, for some
reason, between Ontario and Boston.
I might look into that and see how I can sell
even more.
So what have we seen?
What we've seen is the introduction in the
GA of mobile apps as a first-class citizen.
So we've seen the sign-up flow, the new reporting.
Next what I'd like to look at is how you actually
add this to your application.
To begin with, let's look at the architecture
and let's look at the architecture of a Web
site.
You've got a Web site to which you are adding
analytics.
What happens is you have a Web page that includes
GA, Google analytics.js, JavaScript.
This JavaScript has an API on it and you can
then track various things, including events,
and pages views and so on and those get sent
down to the cloud there which is the Google
analytics back end.
And it's very straightforward and simple.
It's a little more complicated in the mobile
case.
First off, you're not downloading JavaScript
dynamically, right?
Instead, you have an SDK that's linked with
your application.
That SDK will then accept tracking calls from
your application, and unfortunately, it can't
send them directly to our back end.
For a couple reasons.
Give me one reason.
>>Neil Rhodes: What's that?
>>> Power.
>>Neil Rhodes: Power's a good reason.
So we wouldn't want, every time you switch
screens, to be powering up the radio and sending
out hits across the Internet.
The second reason is if we -- even if we did
power up the radio, maybe there's nothing
there, right?
You're on an airplane or in a tunnel or something
else.
So we don't necessarily have Internet connectivity.
And even if we did, it's not clear we want
to be using it immediately.
So instead we queue those hits in a local
database and then those get dispatched on
a periodic basis.
As well, you can request a dispatch manually.
So if you're already making some connection
to the network, that's a good time to request
a manual dispatch because we can then piggyback
on top of your connection which is good for
battery life.
So let's look at the steps you need to take
in order to add analytics.
And there are really four basic ones to get
started.
We'll talk of -- in a moment of additional
things you can do.
So these four steps are to add the jar file
to your project.
In this case I'm going to be talking mostly
about the Android, although some asides about
iOS specific.
For iOS don't add a jar file, okay, for iOS
add dot.hn.a file.
So we first add the jar file, and actually
I'm going to talk about this somewhat briefly
because I'm going to go through a live demo.
The second thing is add a configuration file.
On iOS you're going to actually be doing this
in code, and the reason for that is in iOS,
it's very -- you have a single place when
your application gets started.
You can go ahead and do initialization.
For Android your application starts because
some activity starts and so we don't want
to have to duplicate that code with every
activity.
So instead, we provide an XML file with configuration
information that we read from.
So the most important configuration piece
is that tracking ID you got when you created
the account.
UA-number, number, dash, number.
The second thing I always like to turn on
for development is GAD bug.
So turning that on will provide additional
debugging information to the console so that
you actually know analytics are working, things
are happening.
The third thing is auto activity tracking.
And this is specific to Android.
If your application is designed as a set of
activities, each of which roughly corresponds
to a screen, as the travel application was,
then you would want to turn this on.
And so as a user switches from activity to
activity, we will automatically track those
as different screens.
I'll talk a little bit later on in cases where
that wouldn't make sense.
And the final thing we're turning on here
is reporting uncaught exceptions.
This will install an uncaught exception handler,
what I think of as an exception handler of
last resort which will take an exception that
is about to abort your application and go
ahead and track that and send that to Google
analytics.
There are a couple of configurations you can
do as well and they're documented.
So that's number two.
Number three, update your manifest.
The most important two things are a set of
permissions, right?
You need to be able to connect to the Internet
so you need to set that permission.
And we need to know what the network state
is so you need to set that as well.
I've mentioned the fact that analytics provides
information about where you're coming from
the application, okay?
Sorry, how your application gets installed,
how users go into Google Play and Google Play
has to provide information to analytics and
that's done with an install receiver.
So there is a notification that's made when
Google Play installs your app, we handle that
notification, grab this campaign information,
and then we'll send it the first time the
user uses your application.
The final thing you need to do is actually
add some code.
You need to tell analytics that you're starting,
so in every one of your activities you need
to overwrite on start and on stop and call
analytics SDK.
We do provide a tracked activity class that
just does exactly this, so if you just want
to subclass from that that's fine as well.
so what I'd like to do is a quick demo of
actually doing this just to show you kind
of how simple it is.
So I'm going to create a new Android project
from one of the samples that ships with the
SDK.
I'm going to use the notepad example.
All right.
And step one was to go ahead and add the jar
file.
So I'm going to go ahead and create a libs
directory.
Which already exists.
Which is quite odd.
Since I just created this from scratch.
So here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to create a new Android project
and I'm going to name it notepad 2 and I'm
sure that will solve all the problems.
Because I'm quite suspicious when code suddenly
appears there automatically.
And there's no libs directory there, so that's
looking better.
So I have a libs directory.
And I'm going to go ahead and drag over my
jar file.
And that's step I need to do.
Step two I need to do is I need to tell Eclipse
to go ahead and use that jar file as part
of the class path.
So I'm going to configure the build path,
add the jar file, okay.
That's step one done.
Step two, I said, was we need to create an
XML file for configuration.
So I'm going to create a folder for that.
Create an XML file and call it whatever you
want.
I'm going to call it analytics.XML and it's
going to have values.
And then go ahead and add the values I want.
So I'm going add a string which is the tracking
ID.
So GA_trackingID.
And now I need to remember my UA.
So thank goodness I have it hidden away in
a text file.
Great.
The other things I need to add, unfortunately
the visual editor doesn't work for, so I need
to add a Boolean which is GAD_bug.
We'll set that to true.
I had another Boolean which was, let's see,
we want to -- auto activity tracking.
I could do the uncaught exceptions but I happen
to know that notepad doesn't have exceptions.
The last thing I need to do is I want, for
debugging purposes only, to adjust the dispatch
period.
And I just want to make it 15 seconds so I
can actually quickly see these hits go out.
We would not ever want to ship with this because
that would basically just keep the radio active
most of the time.
So that was step two.
Step three is the manifest.
And in the manifest I need to add my two permissions.
So the first permission I'm going to add is
accessing the network state.
And the second permission I want to add is
being able to access the Internet.
And what's the final thing I said we needed
to do?
And I'm not going to put in the install receiver
now because I'm not actually planning on installing
this via Google Play.
The last thing is code.
So I'm going to go into the notes list, and
I need to override on start and on stop.
Feel free to tell me if I make any typos.
Okay.
So that's my onstart.
My onstop looks very similar except we stay
stop instead of start.
There are three activities in this application.
For the other two, the subclass activity,
I'm going to go ahead and subclass tracked
activity.
As I mentioned, that's exactly the same thing,
it just overrides it on start and on stop.
And the title editor is the final one.
Import it.
And I think we're good to go.
So let's go ahead and run this application.
Okay.
So we can see it's uploading it on to the
emulator.
You know, that reminds me of something.
All this is running.
I'm going to go back to the analytics report
because there was run report I intended to
show you that I forgot.
And that is a report that started coming out
last year, I believe, which is real time.
And I want you to know that real time works
for applications as well.
So switching away a second, I want to have
an application that uses real time.
This notepad is going to have one user.
My Acme application doesn't have really any
right now but there's one that you all have
which is the I/O app.
So if you all pull out your phones and pull
out the Google I/O app.
So the Google I/O app right now has 210 users.
Okay?
We see -- and as you use it, and go ahead
and sync so what happens with the Google I/O
app is it doesn't actually send the hits back
to analytics until it's actually synching
so it can piggyback and do that so you're
going to see more and more users coming on
here as you start using the application.
So 215 applica- -- 216 users.
Most of them are using the agenda, which is
not surprising.
But there are other people in various other
screens, most of them Friday screens, which
is not surprising, again, not using Thursday,
not using Wednesday.
So this allows you to see how many users are
using your mobile application, in this case,
in the last 30 minutes, and in this case,
in the last minute.
If we go back to the notepad, I can see in
the log that we actually have hits being sent,
so I can see this get and I get to see actually
what the particulars of the hit that's being
sent.
So that's my indication that this is working
correctly.
I'd really like to be able to see this, so
for some reason I can't unlock this.
But I know the notepad actually opened.
You can actually also -- this is a useful
use of real time.
So in this case this is the notepad, real
time.
And I get to see, I have one user of about
four minutes ago, which is when I first launched
the application.
That's a good way you can quickly verify that
your application is getting information back
to Analytics.
Okay.
So we've seen today what we have.
We've seen the reports, we've seen how you
add analytics to your application.
There's other code you might want to add to
your application.
Tracking views manually.
This would be the case if you have a game
application where you have a single activity
and users are moving from level to level in
your game.
So you would want to call trackview as they
enter a new level.
Or if you've got your application organized
as fragments as users display one fragment
or another fragment, you would want to trackview.
Events I talked about, the what is happening
in your application.
We have a three-level hierarchy of strings
as well as a value associated with each event.
E-commerce, so you have any sort of e-commerce
in your application, as we did in the travel
app, you can record it here.
It's basically transaction consists of one
or more items, each of which can have their
own quantity and price.
Exceptions, so you can use the uncut exception
handler or catch your own exceptions.
In this case, the false means it's not fatal.
You can provide the raw exception in which
case we will summarize it for you.
Or you can provide a textual description on
your own.
And timing; timing can be really useful to
optimize your application and user's experience
of that application.
You might want to keep timing, for instance,
of how long it takes to sync your application
to your backend, or how long it takes to load
a new level in your game.
And then get that information in your reports
and find out there may be out layers you want
to go fix.
So I've seen what we have today.
Let me look at an upcoming feature that I'm
really excited about.
And that is, integration with Google Play.
When you are creating an account, you have
the option of linking that to a Google Play
account.
We will show you then all of the applications
you have in that Google Play account.
You probably don't have Gmail and YouTube.
We at Google do.
You will see your icons for your applications
and you can then link an application to your
account.
How is that useful?
Well, we have a report that shows you how
users are getting -- you've already seen how
users get to your application, right?
We now have some extra information that we
can show about how many users may get to your
page in Google Play and of those how many
actually download the application.
Right?
Because there's definitely a difference there,
right?
You've got people who go to Google Play, see
your page and see side, nah, this isn't for
me.
You can see how people differentially download
based on how they are coming in.
Are they coming in via Google search, AdWords,
so on.
This can allow you to optimize your campaigns
as well as optimize your Google Play page.
What might you do?
You might adjust your screen shots.
You might adjust your copy.
And you might find you want to get better
reviews by whatever means you can do that.
One more thing.
I'd like to go ahead and bring Nick up on
board, to show you something else exciting
in the space of Analytics and mobile applications.
[ Applause ]
>>Nick Mihailovksi: Thanks Neil.
My name is Nick Mihailovski.
Where's the clicker.
Thank you.
All right.
I'm going to get you guys awake because I
know it's late in the day and Analytics is
probably -- for me it's one of my favorite
subjects.
So my name is Nick Mihailovski.
I'm a developer programs engineer on Analytics.
I'm really excited here to talk about one
more thing that we have.
Now, typically most people who use Google
Analytics log into the web interface and view
their data.
But what happens if you're away from your
desk?
Like if you're traveling and you want to view
your data on the go.
In the past, it's been difficult.
The experience hasn't been that great.
You either have to go and boot up your computer
or you are going to have to go and go to your
mobile device and look at the browser and
the experience wasn't optimized until today.
Today we're launching --
[ Applause ]
>>Nick Mihailovksi: Wooh!
All right.
Today we are launching a new Google Analytics
mobile application that allows you to view
your data directly from your Android device.
Now, if all things work well, it's -- if all
things work well, I'm going to try to show
you a demo from my device.
Let's see if the Wi-Fi cooperates here.
All right.
Hopefully nobody calls me either.
So here I have Analytics app on the phone.
I'm going to turn it on.
First thing what we do is we show you a list
of all the profiles that you have access to.
So the demo I'm going to give you today is
Google I/O app, the same one Neil showed you.
I'm going to go ahead and click on that.
The first thing we show you is the dashboard.
This is a quick way for you to view your key
performance metrics.
What's nice about this dashboard, it's completely
customizable.
So right here, the default view will show
you the total number of active users for the
I/O app.
Notice how the number of active users has
increased because everybody is using the app
at I/O.
Now what I could do is click this plus button,
I have a full list of different metrics I
can use to add to this dashboard.
I'm really interested in crashes.
Crashes should not happen on an app especially
when everybody is using it.
Let's go ahead and click on the crashes metric.
I can configure this to change and apply advanced
segments.
I could change the date range, bunch of stuff.
For you guys, we will use the default view.
Go back.
Boom.
There you have daily crashes in the palm of
your hands.
Pretty cool.
So here's a little story on the next feature
that I think was really cool and is really
applicable.
So for the keynote, I was standing there in
line with my buddy Antonio Rosso.
We are standing in this line.
Thousands of people around us.
Everybody is trying to get into the keynote
for I/O.
We started to chat about how this year at
I/O the audience is bigger, things are better.
The new mobile I/O app is so much better,
it's easier to use.
We look around, he asks me, I wonder how many
people are using the mobile app.
I look at him and smile.
I showed him this view.
Which is realtime reporting in Analytics.
Now, I probably don't have a connection here,
so you can't see the data because it's realtime
and since there's no connection, you're not
going to see information here.
But what we are doing is we are bringing realtime,
up-to-the-second reporting directly in the
palm of your hands.
So at the time when we were looking at the
data, we saw about 5,000 different people
using the app right there.
And I swear this works because I was sitting
right here and I was looking at it the whole
time changing networks and, of course, when
I have to do the demo, there's no connection.
It's setup to work on Google I/O.
So what we will do here is we will show you
a metric of the total number of users whether
it's in your web site or your application.
So if you're at the movie theater looking
at your metrics, if you're in a board room
meeting and kind of sneaking a view, you have
up-to-the-minute reports of what's going on
in your site.
Now, in Google Analytics there's over 200
metrics you can analyze.
That can be difficult to analyze all that
data on such a small device.
A couple of years ago we launched what we
call Google Analytics Intelligence.
Now, Google Analytics Intelligence mines all
your data and finds statistically significant
changes and shows those in a report.
It's pretty much a what's change report.
To make analysis easy on the device, we incorporated
Google Analytics Intelligence directly in
a view.
What this shows you is a list of the top things
that have changed on your site, ordered by
day and by statistical significance.
And so when you click on the first link, what
we see is that in San Francisco the number
of sessions has increased by 500% and that's
an anomaly in our data set.
You can see by the data-over-time graph that
there's a huge increase of data right there.
Now, when you're looking at this data, you
might be, again, waiting to get on a plane
or eating dinner, and you want to share this
with your team at home.
We made this easy to share by clicking this
button.
You can send this report to your team back
at home.
So that's a high level review of the Google
Analytics mobile application.
The app is free.
It will be available through Google Play within
a couple hours.
With that, I want to bring Neil back on stage.
[ Applause ]
>>Neil Rhodes: Thanks very much, Nick.
So let's summarize.
We've shown you Google mobile app Analytics
which brings mobile applications as a first-class
citizen into Google Analytics.
If you go to this link goo.gl/E8ULI, you can
go ahead and sign up for the whitelist.
Whitelist will be available in waves starting
Monday, and the good news that I have for
recall of you at I/O is that you all at I/O
have preference over anyone else.
[ Applause ]
>>Nick Mihailovksi: Let's be clear, if you
want to use this application tracking, this
brand new stuff, sign up right now because
a lot of other people will sign up and you
guys will have preference.
>>Neil Rhodes: When he says right now, wait
until the session is over.
All right.
Second thing we showed is -- so what will
happen, you will get an email.
User will be enabled to go create app profiles.
You can go download the SDK, look at the docs,
create applications that use it, start sending
the data, seeing the reports and so on.
So it's all there.
The second thing we have launched today is
a Google Analytics Android app, which Nick
just showed you and which we are really excited
about.
Here's the link for it.
As Nick said, it should be available in the
next couple of hours.
There's a QR code not too useful for those
of you here.
If you happen to be streaming this, it might
be useful.
With that, we thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Neil Rhodes: So let's now open it up for
questions.
Just to let you know, by the way, Nick and
I will be available after this session.
We will go out in the hallway and then we
will make our way down to lunch.
You're free to join us.
Any questions?
Let's go ahead with questions?
>>> Hi.
So if I were already using Google Analytics
for my app and there's already data, like
a lot of Analytics information on there, what's
the migration path?
How do I migrate to --
>>Neil Rhodes: So you are already using Google
Analytics for mobile app?
>>> Yes.
>>Neil Rhodes: So unfortunately, you really
need to just switch over to use the new and
you're not going to be able to see your new
and old data.
>>> Okay.
Is there a plan, though, for the migration?
>>Neil Rhodes: So, no, unfortunately.
This was really -- just the old mobile SDK
was a labs feature, we don't have a migration.
>>> Thanks.
>>> Basic question, when you were on the dashboard
for Google Play showing the traffic sources,
do you have to input those choices manually
or does it auto recognize where you're traffic
is coming from.
>>Neil Rhodes: The traffic sources are auto
recognized for everything except the email
campaign there.
So in general, we have manual campaign tracking
and auto tracking that happens.
>>> Can I go back to those traffic sources
and look at future retention and actions from
those traffic sources, or is it only showing
me app open on the initial launch?
>>Neil Rhodes: What happens is that when you
have a traffic source, that information is
maintained across the lifetime of that user,
and so we can still see information, for instance,
of what happens on those users in the future.
>>Nick Mihailovski: So if you have in-app
transactions, you can then attribute that
back to the original ad that sent them to
download your app.
>>> Beautiful, that helps me with lifetime
value and retention.
Thank you.
>>Neil Rhodes: Question.
>>> Two questions.
The first one is maybe a bit broad.
Can you give an overview of how yourselves
compares to your competitors like Flurry?
>>Neil Rhodes: So, we provide somewhat -- well,
we both are analytics and we provide additional
features that --
>>> Google Play, that one.
>>Neil Rhodes: Let me back up a second.
Having multiple choices is good for users
and we are going to let users decide which
they prefer.
>>> Okay.
Well then the other question was more specifically
about one of the features that they have is
about, you can tie parameters to events.
Like when you have an event for the levels,
player has beaten a level, you can add statistics
about how they did in that level.
When I last looked at Google Analytics, you
could only say just an event.
Is there anything to allow to tie the extra
parameters to it.
>>Nick Mihailovksi: That's a great question.
We released a feature called custom variables
in the previous SDK.
That's something we are looking to bring to
the new SDK.
If you look at our documentation and read
about custom variables, you will see they
give you the ability to add meta data around
the type of stuff you want to bring, your
business data into our product.
>>> That's useful.
>>> My question is about pausing the application.
So when the application -- when user pauses
the app duty, say by pressing the home key,
is that considered a user leaving the screen?
>>Neil Rhodes: So when the user leaves the
application, for instance by going to the
home screen, that is considered leaving that
screen, yes.
>>> That's considered a drop of the user?
>>Neil Rhodes: So the question as to whether
that causes a new session or not is up -- we
actually have a timing mechanism so that you
can specify sort of how long the user is away
from the app before we consider that a new
session.
>>> Is that part of the SDK?
>>Neil Rhodes: Yes.
>>> Thanks.
>>> I actually have two questions.
So number one is, is there a limit of number
he of events the client library will track
per day?
>>Nick Mihailovksi: A limit of 500 requests
per session.
>>> And number two, is there a export API?
For example, if you came up with new query
that, for example, Google doesn't support
right now, but you wanted to run against that
data, do you have an export API to grab that
data, or not.
>>Nick Mihailovksi: We do.
We call it our core reporting API.
If you go to developer.android.com/Analytics,
there's a lot of resources around how to use
that.
>>Neil Rhodes: Just to make clear, we do not
export the raw data.
We export reports.
>>> Okay.
>>Neil Rhodes: So aggregated data.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Question about the refer attribute or
the receiver from Google Play.
We had some issues about this previously when
you have various people managing campaigns,
the operating system sends one receiver value
and not all the receivers.
So you're in a unique place to kind of push
back on that and say it needs to be a broadcast
so that more than one receiver can get that
information.
>>Neil Rhodes: It's true, it is kind of clumsy
if you have multiple receivers associated
with your application.
I think I'm addressing your issue.
You need to write a meta receiver that then
dispatches it to the others.
It is kind of clumsy.
We'll take that information back to the Android
team.
>>> Thanks for the presentation.
The question is about the Android developer
console.
Right now there are some stats there.
What's the crossover between Analytics and
the console that you can see for your applications?
>>Neil Rhodes: We are trying to integrate
that more.
We're working on it.
>>> Will it be a subset or --
>>Nick Mihailovksi: One of the stuff that
Neil was talking about was deeper play integration.
Some of the metrics they are giving your there
are about how people engage on the site.
Analytics gives you more in-app usage and
they give you more within your listing on
the actual play product.
The integration that we are looking to do
is give you holistic end-to-end measurement
so you have full visibility in how to gain
more people to come to your site, how you
can optimize the copy in-play and get more
people to download and transact.
Neil talked about some stuff coming out looking
forward a little bit.
You can consider those integrations getting
deeper and deeper.
>>> Great.
Thank you.
>>> How easy is it to cohort analysis looking
at the user engagement over time with WebKit
and things like that?
>>Nick Mihailovksi: So for cohort analysis,
we do show you the total number of users and
active users on the site.
It's something that we are looking at to give
you the right -- to be able to segment them
properly.
There are deeper things to do.
Something we are still looking at.
>>> How realtime is the data?
>>Nick Mihailovksi: Realtime is within a couple
seconds when you have an Internet connection.
[ Laughter ]
>>Neil Rhodes: For the realtime.
What we say sometimes is, at least for the
web site, we know before the user knows.
So before the user sees the page, we can already
know that they have been there, which I think
is interesting.
>>> Is there any plan to add support for other
mobile platforms?
Like Windows phone or Blackberry?
>>Neil Rhodes: We are looking into other platforms,
yes.
>>Nick Mihailovksi: There's a trade-off on
market share, too, so we want to go where
developers are.
>>Neil Rhodes: And we are also investigating
ways this which third parties could provide
that.
>>> Can you explain how you define the concept
of session and time spent and how it's different
from the web?
>>Neil Rhodes: So it's -- a session length
consists of, when you enter the first activity
until you leave -- until you -- let's make
it clear.
So it's a little complicated by the fact,
of course, that on Android your application
is still running even in the background, right?
So it's when you leave an activity and don't
start a new activity and then stay out for
some certain period of time.
I think the default is 30 seconds maybe.
Although I don't remember and that is configurable.
In addition, if you've got a period of inactivity
for at least 30 minutes that, will also be
considered stopping a session.
>>> So like if you're playing a long-form
video, is that considered activity?
Like say if you are watching an hour-long
movie.
>>Neil Rhodes: As long as you are making tracking
calls at least every 30 minutes, then that
will be considered the same session.
But that's a good example where you would
want to explicitly make calls to -- for instance,
track the event that they are 15 minutes in,
30 minutes in, 45 minutes in, so on, so you
can get some idea.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Can I label my users as a custom cohort?
Does the old segmentation feature of Google
Analytics work?
>>Neil Rhodes: Segmentation feature certainly
works.
If you want to be labeling them in the form
of custom variables, then, no, that is not
there now.
>>> Another question, I think the play integration
is a killer feature, by the way, and sets
you apart from Flurry.
Two-part question, one, I would love to see
more data coming in Google Play, like this
cohort gives me a 30% lower rating than this
other cohort.
The question is, is this exposed in a way
that other SDKs could theoretically grab that
data through the receiver or some other way?
>>Neil Rhodes: So the -- first off, that's
very useful information about the suggestion
for the Google Play.
Things like how well they rate and so on.
The aggregated -- there's a couple answers.
So the aggregated information is certainly
available through the export API.
The receiver information is available to any
application.
So you can know the campaign that caused them
to get to Google Play.
The actual information from Google Play as
terms of number of views and things like that,
there's no API that I know of, at least at
this point, and I don't know of any plans
for one.
>>> Thanks.
>>> I have two questions.
One is are you planning to release the source
code of the Analytics app for Android.
>>Nick Mihailovksi: Application to see your
data, probably not.
We have API, and there's people who built
their own frontends.
But for this one, we will probably own it
ourselves.
>>> Is there a way to track uninstalls with
the new feature of Google Analytics?
>>Neil Rhodes: There is currently no way to
track uninstalls.
That is not to say we won't have that as part
of Google Play integration.
>>> Is there any support for app widgets as
part of the launch?
>>Nick Mihailovksi: So we're providing the
framework to do the tracking and so that's
some of the more documentation on how to use
the framework to do that.
We would probably look to go do it within
the next couple quarters.
There will be more better support for that
type of stuff in the future.
>>Neil Rhodes: But it can be used today.
There's nothing that requires you to have
activities in order to do tracking.
There's sort of a lower level of just initialize
the tracker and start making tracking calls.
You can certainly do that from a widget.
>>Nick Mihailovksi: Just there's a guy right
here, Andrew, he is on our team, and somebody
maybe you want to talk to to figure out some
of the use cases.
>>> What is the minimum Android API required?
>>Neil Rhodes: That is a great question that
I should know the answer to off the top of
my head.
I believe it's 2.1.
It's certainly no later than that.
Does that work for you?
No?
Okay.
>>> In the XML document, you have a debug
mode and you have to differentiate something
like the dispatch time.
Is there a good way to set that so, like,
I have a debug application, is there a good
way to differentiate?
Not just keep switching the string for the
ID, string for the debug.
>>Neil Rhodes: Yeah, I can understand where
that XML -- you want to be able to do programmatically,
perhaps.
You can certainly do it programmatically as
well.
You can leave it out of your XML file and
just make a programmatic call to either turn
the debugger on or off depending on your debugger
setting.
>>> In app starter?
>>Neil Rhodes: Yes.
All that stuff is also available programmatically.
We'll take the last question.
>>> Earlier you mentioned there was a 500
limit per session.
What happens after you hit that?
Does it just dump off the frontend?
Does it stop recording?
>>Neil Rhodes: So that limitation is actually
on the backend rather than in the SDK.
And so what actually happens when you exceed
500 is undefined in practice.
So but it could change, you know, in an hour.
It drops everything past the 500.
>>> Thank you.
>>Neil Rhodes: I'm not lying about that, am
I?
Okay.
Thanks very much.
We certainly appreciate it.
We will be out in the hallway if you have
other questions.